concentrer sur le pilotage de sa
moissonneuse s'il est le blin entame sa
première récolte de quinoa en pleine
découverte de sa nouvelle culture
ils arrêtent souvent son engin pour
veiller au grain donc là je regarde un
petit peu le pourcentage de graines par
rapport aux impuretés
c'est salaire correct cyril a planté
deux hectares et demi de quinoa à
montagny-lès-beaune la culture du quinoa
en bio est plus difficile mais pour
cyril cela en vaut la peine
à 8500 euros la tonne le quinoa rapporte
dix fois plus que du blé on a du mal
avec les conditions climatiques a trouvé
des nos plantes habituel donc on essaye
de trouver autre chose qu'ils peuvent
nous différencier et pikine qui apporte
une plus-value à l'exploitation
et puis en même temps une motivation
qu'on ne connaît pas puisque la
technique on la connaît pas la plante on
la connaît pas donc on s'approprie et on
se fait nous mêmes donc c'est assez
intéressant motivant planté sur la
cordillère des andes depuis 7000 ans le
quinoa est seulement cultivé en france
depuis une dizaine d'années
principalement en anjou alors un kino à
100% bourguignon église forcément les
appétits amis de cyril ce restaurateur
de volnay l'a encouragé à se lancer
impatient de pouvoir en proposer à ses
clients étaient raisonnement
vous remplacez les pâtes par les
kinoises tous les maîtres eux mêmes qui
nous a donné bouillon dans des soupes
pouvait faire avec la farine de quinoa
préfère des desserts ce qui est très
intéressant parce que c'est zéro gluten
ces riches en fibres c'est un module la
glycémie
c'est il ya huit acides aminés
essentiels qui n'est pas rien qu'on
trouve pas dans les céréales complètes
même dans les céréales complètes donc
surtout que c'est quelque chose qui est
très très riche
quant à cyril il envisage déjà de
cultiver plus de quinoa pour les années
à venir une plante qui résiste plutôt
bien aux sécheresse chronique dont
souffre la région depuis plusieurs
années